[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about the only filmmaker who would turn
an innocent dairy indulgence into
something totally sinister i
drink your
milkshake
i drink it up that's right paul thomas
anderson husband to maya rudolph
reformed 90s bad boy and undoubtedly one
of the most interesting filmmakers of
our time every frame sound and word in
pta's filmography feels totally
intentional and so analyzing his work
seems more fitting for a phd in film
studies than for this humble youtube
channel but in the spirit of better
appreciating his latest installment
licorice pizza we thought it'd be worth
looking at a couple of intersecting
themes that seem to permeate his films
specifically family and capitalism and
the uneasy tension between the two so
climb aboard our culty ship and descend
into our bubbly oil well in this
wisecrack edition on how paul thomas
anderson portrays capitalism and family
and warning various levels of spoilers
ahead for several of his films so maybe
treat yourself to a pta marathon before
you keep watching but before we get into
it i want to make sure that you notice
the wisecrack hat and shirt that i'm
currently wearing now on me
wearing wisecrack gear is just one more
way i'm eroding my work life balance
but on you a wisecractee would signify
that hey i enjoy watching a small group
of nerds analyzing the out of pop
culture or maybe you want everyone to
know that you're the world's preeminent
expert on the sexual proclivities of mr
nimbus in which case a sticker for our
podcast the squanch will do the trick
want to signify that you have a literal
thirst for knowledge we've got a mug for
that so visit wisecrack.store to see
everything in our merch collection and
use code new year at checkout and you'll
get 10 off your order through january
7th thank you guys so much for all your
support and now back to the show now
let's start by taking a brief look at
licorice pizza which explores a
blossoming romance between two
youngsters in the 1970s san fernando
valley you have teen gary serial
entrepreneur and child actor who does
not seem bound for thespian greatness
and there's alana the wayward
20-something who seems to lack purpose
they form an unlikely bond as they
co-navigate the most difficult task a
young person can face hanging on to your
youthful naivete before being sucked
into the weird ugly world of adulthood
they also manage to start a water bed
company and avoid getting murdered by a
psycho-sexual freak played by bradley
cooper
perhaps more so than most directors
anderson's work is thematically diverse
and wide-ranging encompassing heavy
drama
[Music]
what i mean
what i believe
is that you killed his father and so on
still at first glance the heartwarming
and at times very sweet licorice pizza
might seem like a strange pivot after
all it comes from the brain behind
intense gutting films like there will be
blood the master and magnolia but upon
closer examination it's really right at
home in his repertoire and not just
because it takes place in anderson's
beloved san fernando valley see gary and
alana along with gary's goofy friends
create a sort of surrogate family and
it's one founded in part out of their
own estrangement and or lack of
emotional fulfillment in their own
families gary's dad is out of the
picture and the kid's mom feels more
like a business partner than a maternal
figure alana's deeply out of place in
her conservative jewish family and her
interactions with them tend to devolve
into impressive screaming matches listen
young lady you don't bring this idiot to
shabbat dinner here listen dad he's an
atheist and an actor and he's famous but
he's jewish he was gonna take me out of
here this is fitting the families are at
the core of much of anderson's work for
his part anderson even told the village
voice that it's the simplest most direct
way i can say it my movies are about
family and those explorations of
biological family are defined by
dysfunction in his early film boogie
nights marky mark's dirk diggler has an
abusive mother who bullies him until he
flees home you're a loser you'll always
be a loser you couldn't even finish high
school because you were so stupid so
what are you gonna do similarly the film
magnolia is anchored in failed
father-child relationships that simmer
with long-term hatred over abandonment
and abuse
listen to me right now claudia
i am dying
i got sick and i fell down
get up
at my house and punch drunk love
features a deeply dysfunctional family
of siblings with seven overbearing
sisters sending adam sandler's berry
into a state of perpetual submission
punctuated by violent rage
in the absence or complete breakdown of
biological family many of anderson's
characters seek out surrogate familial
relationships boogie nights shows dirk
finding an unlikely makeshift family in
the world of pornography the film makes
these intentions abundantly clear i love
you mom
i want you to be my mom amber magnolia
is similarly peppered with unlikely
bonds between its deeply distressed
characters in it a kind nurse and
bumbling police officer provide much of
the emotional comfort the biological
families have failed to offer in punch
drunk love it's only when barry meets a
patient love interest who provides him
with emotional support and understanding
that he can grow and stand up for
himself i have a love in my life
it makes me stronger than anything you
can imagine but of course this is pta
and sometimes he wants to kick you in
the kidney so in his films surrogate
families aren't all fun games and
vaguely terrifying declarations of love
like the other films there will be blood
and the master also show surrogate
families specifically father-son
relationships but these relationships
are a lot more complicated and at times
a lot uglier than the ones we've
previously mentioned and that's because
of a little something called
capitalism and specifically that unique
brand of american capitalism and there
will be blood daniel the obsessive oil
prospector adopts his dead employees
child hw and basically treats him like a
son
however early on we watched daniel pitch
himself to small town folks invoking his
status as a father to win their approval
i'm a family man this scene gives us our
first icky feeling that maybe his
relationship with hw is less about love
and more about practicality having his
son humanizes him in the eyes of the
townspeople whose land he wants to
aggressively drill we suspect daniel
does care about hw somewhat indeed he
seems to feel guilty about sending him
away after the child goes deaf i've
abandoned my child but eventually he
cruelly admits that their relationship
was rooted in economic utility and i
took you for no other reason than i
needed a sweet face to buy land
fittingly when hw decides to start his
own oil business effectively becoming
daniel's competitor this severs their
ties for good no longer business
partners there's no relationship left to
preserve at least in daniel's eyes
capitalistic interest it seems was the
foundation of their family notably the
film also shows daniel's mere image in
the character of eli the ambitious
preacher who creates a symbiotic
relationship with daniel stirring the
prospector's long-suffering oil men into
a frenzy in his evangelical church
daniel brings more people to the town
for brutally hard work those people seek
comfort from eli and thus both men grow
rich in this film capitalism isn't just
entrenched in the family it even invades
the most supposedly sacred arena of life
religion and by the end of the film pta
seems to indicate that religion has
become just as slimy and capitalistic as
oil prospecting he expands on this theme
with his next film the master which is
loosely based on the life of l ron
hubbard it too explores familial
relationships at the intersection of
capitalism and religion freddy's a
violent traumatized soldier who can only
find comfort in sex and booze tell me
what you see
well that's
ladies
what about this one
looks like going inside
in particular
he a sand lady he seeks out a
father figure for direction who in an on
the nose move even goes by the moniker
of master basically a more successful
version of eli with a bit of a naughty
side philip seymour hoffman's lancaster
dodd has successfully merged capitalism
and religion he grows rich off the
wealthy patrons who seek his help to
cope with the cultural malaise and
alienation that followed world war ii
while freddy would otherwise be stuck at
the margins of society joining the
makeshift family of the cause gives him
purpose and makes him feel useful and
even though freddy being useful often
looks pretty violent
his devotion to his father figure helps
him assimilate back into organized
society but of course this relationship
is still largely transactional freddie's
a case study who helps lancaster promote
his theories and practices methods for
the amusement of his followers touch it
and describe it to me
[Music]
uh
just one wall sure there's a true
emotional connection between the two men
perhaps even bordering on homo eroticism
love to get you
[Music]
on a slow
boat to china but the relationship's
basic structure is a capitalist one of
dominance and exploitation and freddie
eventually decides that he has to break
free
for if you figure a way to live
without serving a master
any master
then let the rest of us know unlike
there will be blood in this case the sun
chooses to sever the capitalist
relationship still the two movies
function as fun-house images of one
another the difficulty of finding true
human connection within a capitalist
framework is best explored in these two
films but the theme is percolating
throughout pta's earlier works the
relationships in boogie nights are
founded on mutual capitalist desires
dirk's producer and father figure sees
the kid first and foremost as a
commodity with all this muscly youth and
big ambition it's easy to predict that
after only two films that digler's
success can only grow and grow and grow
then dirk's embrace of fame and fortune
leads him to seek pleasure and
consumption above all else thus
fracturing the relationships he's built
and when he's replaced by younger hotter
competition he views his producer's
rational business decision as an
emotional betrayal and so another
relationship bites the dust via the
scourge of capitalist greed now the film
ends more hopefully than there will be
blood or the master with dirk returning
to his found parents in search of solace
but it nevertheless explores the
difficulty of relationships that are
predicated on mutual business interests
punch drunk glove explores a somewhat
similar predicament on a smaller scale
as barry struggles to succeed selling
toilet blenders we've been working on
this and we have an unbreakable handle
finally
let me demonstrate for you
despite never having boarded a plane he
hoards airline miles via pudding cups in
hopes that tricking the system will make
him feel smart and a little less
powerless he calls a phone sex chat line
offering up all of his information and
hopes of finding some brief romantic
solace he's rewarded with deranged
threatening demands for more money that
underscore what he was to begin with a
mark for the greed of the georgia peach
on the other side of the phone maybe i
should call back and talk to your
girlfriend
maybe it'd be better to ask her for the
money
it could be really easy you know barry i
have all your information i have your
credit card information
all of your bills no thank you
throughout his work pta prominently
features salesmen who by nature of their
job form relationships with the
intention of selling as scholar jason
spurb explains in his book blossoms and
blood post-modern media culture in the
films of paul thomas anderson this fits
with his broader themes surrounding
family and modern capitalism as spurb
writes the director is preoccupied with
the disintegration of the biological
family the relationship between
commodities and personal alienation the
shared financial interest that holds
surrogate families together and the
ubiquity of salesmen in everyday life
these salesman characters crop up again
and again
berries hawking toilet plungers bucks
selling sound systems lancaster selling
a new religion daniel's selling towns on
oil deals and in licorice pizza gary and
alana are selling water beds in magnolia
tom cruise's fred mackey masterfully
sells lonely men on pickup artistry he
treats romance as another transaction
sex as another commodity in a system
that can be gamed much as barry gains
his way to a million airline miles
fittingly for a filmmaker preoccupied
with failed father-son relationships pth
child characters are also often valued
for what they can offer monetarily hw as
we mentioned provides a cute face to
temper daniel's aggressive sales pitches
in magnolia stanley a child on the what
do kids know game show is treated like a
meal ticket who might through his
extensive academic knowledge help make
his dad super rich and dirk functionally
a child is valued by his porn family for
his immense popularity which have made
them collectively richer licorice pizza
fittingly also features a child actor
who uses his modest success to help fund
businesses that he runs with his mother
while gary doesn't explicitly
acknowledge this it's made clear that
he's aged out of being a cute and
precocious child actor so he hustles his
way into the business world he wanted to
be a showman but it's clear that he's
more of a classic pta salesman meanwhile
alana is pulled towards the more adult
worlds of hollywood and local politics
to try and distance herself from gary's
seemingly childish pursuits i think it's
weird that i hang out with gary and his
15 year old friends all the time these
twin desires for success and identity
pull them apart but by the end of the
film spoiler alert gary and alana are
back together running through the
streets of the valley and seemingly
running from the inevitable encroachment
of adulthood and the pressures of
american capitalism it's a beautiful but
bittersweet moment as we know they won't
be able to outrun these forces forever
at least not if we've learned from pta's
past films but what do you guys think
does capitalism ruin families or are we
just stripping on poisonous mushrooms
and does licorice pizza fit pta's
overall themes or is it something of an
aberration in his work let us know in
the comments huge thanks to our patrons
for engaging in a symbiotic capitalist
relationship with us and don't forget to
check out our podcast punch that
subscribe button like you're using a
bowling pin to kill a preacher and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
you